nous recevons donc le ministre délégué
de la transition numérique et des
télécommunications bonjour Jean-Noël
Barrault bonjour Philippe avec nous je
disais ministre du vertige vous
comprenez que tous ces enjeux que
couvent votre ministère génère sous
génèrent souvent autant d'angoisse que
d'espérance absolument les technologies
nouvelles que vous avez citées notamment
l'intelligence artificielle l'arrivée de
chat GPT c'est porteurs d'un certain
nombre de promesses pour l'accélération
de la recherche scientifique pour la
création artistique pour même
l'accessibilité de celles et ceux qui
sont éloignés du numérique mais ça
présente évidemment un certain nombre de
dérives de risques de manipulation de
déshumanisation des questions
démocratiques et éthiques que je prends
à bras le corps alors depuis deux
semaines l'affaire des influx voleurs
fait l'actualité je vais résumer les
derniers épisodes deux influenceurs
installés à Dubaï Marc et Nanny Blatta
aurait utilisé leur célébrités pour
inciter leur followers ils sont nombreux
à des investissements soi-disant
magiques en fait très risqué les
investisseurs naïfs et ça un pléonasme
et ont perdu leur argent tandis que
c'est enrichi en prenant des commissions
il y a un collectif qui porte plainte
l'affaire éclate dans les médias les
géants du web finissent par fermer les
comptes Instagram et snapchat de marque
et l'un des Blatta mais ça arrive comme
toujours bien trop tard en attendant les
victimes ont perdu leur argent pendant
des mois ils agissaient en toute
impunité sans que les plateformes ne
fassent rien question ni l'État il faut
d'abord rappeler ce que sont les
influenceurs les réseaux sociaux ont
permis le développement de cette
nouvelle activité qui a un certain
nombre d'avantages puisque certains
influenceurs participent et bien à
l'éducation des publics sur un certain
nombre de thèmes de sujets y compris de
l'éducation scientifique ce qui est
bienvenu on a souvent reçu ici des
professeurs par exemple il y a
effectivement des professeurs qui qui se
sont réinventés en influenceurs et c'est
une bonne chose puisqu'ils apportent de
l'information de premièrement une
qualité sur les réseaux sociaux il y a
aujourd'hui on l'estime 150 000
influenceurs en France mais évidemment
il y a les risques que vous citez celui
des escroqueries celui de la
manipulation
et auquel nous devons apporter une
réponse et c'est la raison pour laquelle
Bruno Le Maire a souhaité que nous
puissions avancer sur ce sujet il a
lancé une consultation en ligne au début
du mois de janvier à laquelle 20 000
personnes ont participé qui va venir
nourrir les travaux menés par des
groupes de réflexion qui ont été lancés
en fin d'année dernière et qui vont
permettre d'aboutir à un certain nombre
de propositions pour faire trois choses
protéger les consommateurs contre les
arnaques accompagner les influenceurs il
n'y a pas de statut aujourd'hui pour
cette nouvelle activité et puis
sanctionner les tricheurs plus
efficacement Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'économie et des finances qu'ils
étaient en personne emparée du sujet
publiquement mais la question que tout
le monde se pose c'est comment fait-on
pour protéger les Français
d'influenceurs pas toujours très honnête
qui vivent à Dubaï et qui les arnaques
sur des réseaux sociaux américains voire
parfois chinois vous savez il est tout à
fait possible de réguler l'espace
numérique pays par pays et c'est ce que
nous faisons en France et en Europe pour
mettre fin à un certain nombre de
pratiques auxquelles ça donne les les
grandes plateformes et donc s'agissant
des influenceurs il est tout à fait
possible de créer des cadres acceptables
d'une activité telle que celle
d'influenceurs et de sanctionner les les
arnaques de sanctionner les tricheries
et de protéger les consommateurs c'est
ce que nous allons faire à l'issue de
ces travaux que Bruno Le Maire enclenché
mais les sanctionnés comment pour
prendre l'exemple j'en parle parce qu'il
y a une double page dans match
absolument saisissante ou un marque
bataille sa compagne dans une voiture à
Dubaï dont même les appuis-tête sont
floqués de leur nom avec cuir qui doit
être hors de prix comment fait-on pour
les sanctionner alors qu'ils ne sont pas
en France la première des choses même si
je veux pas préempter bien sûr le
résultat des travaux qui sont menés
actuellement et Marc data c'est un
exemple je voulais dire quiconque aurait
contrevenu à la loi française mais s'il
est pas en France sur le territoire
comme on fait quand on compte revient à
la à la loi française sur un réseau
social la première des choses c'est
qu'on peut être exclu et exclut
définitivement de toute activité sur ce
réseau là et ensuite lorsqu'on en a
causé des du tort à des ressort en
français et bien il y a des actus en
justice qui peuvent être entreprises
s'agissant d'un contexte nouveau
puisqu'on est sur sur internet avec des
activités qui ne sont pas encore basées
il est nécessaire justement de créer un
cadre qui dise ce qui acceptable et ce
qui ne l'est pas et que les poursuites
éventuelles puissent s'engager sur ce
fondement on est tout à fait d'accord
avec vous la question c'est la réalité
c'est le cadre combien de temps
faudra-t-il pour qu'il soit mis
effectivement en place mardi dernier il
y avait trois Français victimes de
cybarcellement qu'on demandait au
tribunal correctionnel de Paris de
bloquer Twitter qui en ne coopérant pas
que la justice a bloqué l'enquête qui
aboutit à un non-lieu c'est un peu
complexe mais je vous racontais
l'histoire trois personnes une rescapées
du Bataclan le père d'une victime a un
ancien journaliste ont été harcelés et
menacés de mort de façon anonyme pour
avoir défendu le retour en France des
femmes de djihadistes mais quand les
enquêteurs ont sollicité Twitter pour
remonter vers l'identité des auteurs
anonymes la Twitter a refusé de coopérer
et l'affaire on est resté là
si si c'est avéré cette inacceptable car
les plateformes qui diffusent sur le
territoire français et européen doivent
coopérer avec les autorités judiciaires
mais s'agissant plus généralement du
cyber-harcèlement c'est vrai que nous
devons aller plus vite pour traiter ces
problèmes-là nous avons vu il y a
quelques mois les streams ses créatrices
de contenu sur les réseaux sociaux se
manifestaient parce qu'elle considérait
que les atteintes à leur dignité le
cyber seulement dans tel faisait et le
sexisme l'objet et le sexisme dont elle
faisait l'objet n'était pas suffisamment
rapidement traité j'ai réuni avec
Isabelle Rome la ministre de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes c'est
streamers nous les avons entendu nous
avons depuis réuni les plateformes sur
lesquelles ces streamers travaillent et
nous réfléchissons à la fois au niveau
des plateformes mais aussi en termes de
réception des plaintes par la police par
la gendarmerie et de traitement de ces
plaintes parts la justice vous savez que
avec la la loi pour les valeurs de la
République nous avons créé un parquet
numérique mais qu'il faut qu'il que dont
il faut qu'il puisse accélérer ce
traitement des plaintes parce que
certaines situations sont totalement
inacceptable et mettent en danger ces
personnes d'un mot Twitter a été racheté
par Elon Musk je ne vous apprends rien
vous avez la chance de rencontrer elon
must même le privilège l'ordre
déplacement aux États-Unis tel à
l'occasion du CES de Las Vegas avez-vous
eu le temps de lui parler de ces sujets
de harcèlement avec Elon Musk et que
vous dit-il si oui je suis allé voir
Elon Musk pour m'assurer auprès de lui
qu'il est bien en train de prendre
toutes les dispositions pour se
conformer aux règles européennes qui
vont entrer en vigueur cette année ces
règles européennes que vous a-t-il dit
parce que ça qui nous intéresse est-ce
que pour lui en a un tout petit pays
dont il n'a que faire au contraire c'est
important pour lui d'avoir une tête de
pont en Europe ces règles européennes
elles disent que contrairement à ce qui
a été le cas depuis 20 ans
sur Internet les plateformes de réseaux
sociaux les plateformes de marché ont
une responsabilité vis-à-vis des
contenus illicites vis-à-vis du
cyber-harcèlement qui se déroule sur
leur plateforme ça c'est votre point de
vue que vous a-t-il dit il nous a dit
qu'il était d'accord avec les grands
principes il l'avait déjà dit au
président de la République et il nous a
dit que il était en train de prendre les
mesures nécessaires pour adapter Twitter
la plateforme assez nouvelle règle
européennes qu'ils que ces équipes
participeraient aux réunions
préparatoires organisées par la
Commission européenne et que lui-même
éventuellement y participerait
personnellement il viendrait il
viendrait donc nous nous restons
vigilants nous allons regarder avec
attention si oui ou non les mesures sont
prises et le juge de paix et bien ça
sera l'application de ces règles
européennes si elles ne sont pas
appliquées par Twitter c'est dans un
premier temps une amende de 6% du
chiffre d'affaires donc c'est 300
millions d'euros pour Twitter et si
Twitter récidive alors c'est
interdiction de diffusion sur le
territoire européen journal barreau
ministre délégué de la transition
numérique et des télécommunications et
avec nous dans Culture média on va
parler de l'intelligence artificielle
des espoirs et aussi des craintes
qu'elle suscite à tout de suite en
compagnie de journal barreau ministre
délégué de la transition numérique et
des télécommunications vous dépendez du
ministère de l'Économie de Bruno Le
Maire on va parler d'intelligence
artificielle un sujet qui comporte des
enjeux déterminants pour l'avenir à la
fois économique sociaux et politique de
la France sujet qui donne le vertige les
progrès fulgurantes l'IA questions
puisque ça fait partie de votre champ de
compétences où se situe les entreprises
français dans cette guerre qui semble vu
de l'extérieur avoir été gagné par les
Américains les Français sont très en
avance sur l'intelligence artificielle
et dans toutes ces entreprises
américaines notamment qui développent
des solutions d'intelligence
artificielle on retrouve des Français je
pense à Yann Loquin je pense à François
Cholet c'est le patron de l'intelligence
artificielle chez meta absolument nous
venons Facebook absolument nous avons
aussi nous avons aussi une très belle
entreprise fondée par des Français qui
est désormais établi aux États-Unis qui
s'appelle hugging face mais heureusement
nous avons aussi en France les talents
je pense à Stéphane Mala qui qui détient
la chair d'intelligence artificielle au
Collège de France et des laboratoires de
premier rang et donc nous n'avons pas
perdu la bataille et je pense que la
France peut rester dans la course oui
mais de manière industrielle on l'a
perdu il y a pas d'entreprises
françaises il y a des Français qui c'est
le bringen il y a des Français qui vont
travailler pour les Américains mais il y
a plus de Français qui restent en France
comme il y en a chez Peugeot chez
Renault depuis 5 ans depuis le rapport
Villani qui a fait un premier état des
lieux de l'intelligence artificielle
nous investissons massivement en matière
d'intelligence artificielle nous avons
investi 3 milliards et nous allons
continuer pour soutenir le développement
de ce type de modèle comme chat GPT qui
émerge depuis 2019 nous allons former
jusqu'à 8000 professionnels experts de
l'intelligence artificielle chercheur
techniciens juristes pour que la France
puisse rester dans la course c'est pas
un pléonasme auparavant l'intelligence
artificielle pour les gens s'était
artificiel et puis avec l'arrivée de
chat GPT le grand public a vu
concrètement
l'enjeu quel était la révolution qui se
jouait vous avez senti cette différence
de perception
clairement tchat GPT a popularisé
démocratisé l'intelligence artificielle
avec ses promesses dont on parlait tout
à l'heure d'accélération du progrès
technologique il y a un modèle très
similaire à celui de chat GPT qui a
permis d'accélérer considérablement la
recherche sur les molécules mais il y a
des risques de manipulation de
discrimination de non-respects de la
propriété intellectuelle et de
déshumanisation et face à cela nous
voulons agir nous voulons investir je
l'ai dit mais nous voulons aussi mettre
un certain nombre de grands principes de
garde-fou alors pour qu'il n'a jamais vu
fonctionner chagipetti c'est un joli
logiciel accessible gratuitement pour
l'instant à tout le monde il peut faire
beaucoup de choses à notre place par
exemple créer des poésies écrire des
chroniques ou des cours de fac passer
des examens rédiger des dissertations
sur mesure et devant le risque de triche
Sciences Po à interdit vendredi l'usage
de chat GPT questions est-ce que cette
interdiction c'est une solution où
est-ce que c'est de l'obscurantisme qui
ne dit pas son nom
ou plus précisément openéa et
l'entreprise qui a créé chat GPT à
publier il y a quelques jours une
solution à destination des universités
et des écoles pour vérifier si oui ou
non il y a triche ce qu'il faut qu'à
terme parce que comme on peut demander
beaucoup beaucoup de choses à répéter
par exemple des gens sont amusés à
demander écris-moi un scénario qui
puisse plaire à Télérama et on avait
l'impression de lire une chronique de
Télérama mais si
j'ai pété je vais aller au son au fond
de ma question c'est tellement malin
tellement intelligent je crois que c'est
145 milliards de données qui sont
concentrés qui peuvent vous sortir en 10
secondes est-ce qu'on peut lui demander
d'écrire une dissertation dont l'école
de Sciences Po n'arrive pas à
reconnaître qu'elle a été écrite par une
main artificielle non il existe des
moyens de d'identifier si oui ou non
chat GPT a participé à la rédaction d'un
texte le problème c'est que au moment où
tchat j'ai pété a été publié c'est
solution de vérification n'était pas
prête elles sont en train de le devenir
et il sera d'ores et il sera désormais
possible de vérifier si oui ou non il y
a eu triche et c'est évidemment une
bonne chose et je crois que plutôt que
d'essayer de bloquer à tout prix des
modèles comme comme chat GPT il faut
aussi qu'on commence à à éduquer notre
jeunesse à au potentiel de ces de ces
logiciels là et alors usage pour que
nous puissions et bien en avoir la
pleine maîtrise et la pleine
compréhension alors beaucoup sont amusés
à détourner les usages de chats j'ai
pété en s'y prenant bien on peut lui
faire rédiger un texte convaincant qui
démontre que la terre est plate ou que
le cancer se soigne avec du vinaigre
est-ce que c'est pas de la folie de
mettre cet outil dans la main de
comploter de complotistes je l'ai dit ce
type de modèle présente un certain
nombre de dérive alors qu'est-ce que
nous faisons nous d'abord je vais saisir
le comité national pilote pour l'éthique
du numérique c'est une instance qui a
été créée en 2019 par le Président de la
République qui est rattaché au Comité
national d'éthique du professeur
Jean-François delfresci qui avait émis
un avis il y a deux ans sur les agents
qu'on fait conversationnel c'est les
chatbots comme chat GPT et au je vais
demander d'actualiser son avis pour nous
dire si en l'état notre droit est
suffisamment protecteur pour éviter ce
type de dérive et puis en parallèle au
niveau européen nous négocions avec les
autres États membres un règlement sur
l'intelligence artificielle qui va créer
un cadre qui soit à la fois propice à
l'innovation puisque nous voulons que
l'intelligence artificielle se se
développe en Europe pour en garder la
maîtrise mais qui soit aussi
suffisamment protecteur et la France
adore déjà obtenu que les solutions
comme tchat GPT soit intégrées dans le
cadre de ce règlement européen Actu du
matin il y a un juge colombien qui
hésitait dans une décision il a avoué il
a annoncé avoir consulté chaque gipiti
pour rendre son jugement est-ce que
c'est une solution pour régler
l'engorgement des tribunaux est-ce que
l'intelligence artificielle pourrait
remplacer le juge comment vous voyez ça
puisque vous êtes la puissance publique
je vous le dis tout de suite c'est
l'intelligence artificielle type chat
GPT ne pourra pas en Europe en vertu de
ce règlement européen que nous sommes en
train de négocier
être utilisé pour rendre la justice et
je précise au passage que la justice est
rendue au nom du peuple français en
France en tout cas et qu'il est
évidemment inacceptable et
inenvisageable qu'elle puisse être
rendue au nom de quelqu'un d'autre j'ai
la même question que celle que je vous
ai posé au sujet des lendemain ce que
vous avez rencontré les dirigeants
d'Open d'openhail les créateurs de
tchatche Betty lors de votre déplacement
aux États-Unis sur quoi ont porté votre
discours vos discussions et que vous
ont-ils dit précisément sur la manière
de contenir les les dérives en termes de
manipulation en matière de
déshumanisation
ils ont parfaitement conscience que
cette activité nécessite qu'un certain
nombre de garde-fous soient posés que
ces garde-fous peuvent en partie être
posés par le concepteur de la machine
lui-même mais qui en a une autre partie
qui relève du débat démocratique et
qu'il appartient à la puissance publique
de fixer un certain nombre de bornes de
bornes éthiques et il ne le sammaltman
le fondateur est dirigeant d'Open nous
aussi très clairement et là comme ça on
verra les leviers d'action du politique
j'aurais juste vous faire réagir faut
que je trouve voilà l'ancien PDG de
Google Eric Schmitt qui a déclaré
c'était le 27 juillet dernier que
l'intelligence artificielle était aussi
dangereuse que la bombe atomique c'est
comme toute technologie elle peut être
source de progrès d'émancipation de
libération mais elle peut être aussi une
source de régression de repli de
violence et donc il nous appartient d'en
faire le meilleur usage merci beaucoup
Jean-Noël barreau d'être venu ici en
direct dans Culture média je rappelle
que vous êtes ministre de la transition
numérique et des télécommunications
merci encore